à peine entamé la bataille pour l'hôtel
de ville à auxerre a déjà eu raison du
mariage tout récent de la famille
centriste le divorce au niveau local
entre le 10 et le modem est consommé il
n'y aura pas de liste du centre lui dit
andré villiers a choisi son camp il
s'allie avec l'ump il n'a pas digéré
l'appel de bayrou a voté hollande à la
présidentielle
les indications qui sont redescendus de
françois bayrou à ce moment là nous ont
pas autorisés à progresser et bien
écoutez les temps sont quand même
particulièrement troublé faut-il atout
face compter compter sa force politique
et prendre le risque de l'échec un
soutien affiché ce mardi lors du meeting
de lancement de campagne du candidat ump
guillaume larrivé lequel ne devrait pas
manquer de réserver quelques places de
choix à lui dit s'il conquiert la mairie
la présence du patron du centre qui est
aussi le patron du conseil général de
l'yonne andré villiers ce soir à nos
côtés est le signe de cette alliance
extrêmement forte pour construire
l'avenir d'auxerre nous avons besoin de
faire le rassemblement le plus large des
bonnes volontés guillaume larrivé n'aura
pas en tout cas les bonnes volontés du
modem le président départemental du
mouvement un reproche au candidat ump
une attitude jugée floue vis-à-vis du
front national ils y ont vu l'arrivée a
été soutenue et sa femme un petit peu
choqué par le front national aux
dernières initiatives qui a appelé à
voter pour lui je lui avais demandé de
clarifier la situation il n'a pas fait
donc je trouve ça un peu dommage hein
dis pas que c'est quelqu'un de l'extrême
droite loin de là cette idée mais c'est
quelqu'un qui avait des idées sur
l'immigration l'intégration et
différents motifs sujets de société le
mariage pour tous qui sont différents
des miens pas d'alliance modem ump donc
en revanche un rapprochement avec le ps
n'est pas exclu comme à dijon cela
constituerait un coup de canif au
contrat centriste qui prévoyait des
alliances uniquement avec la droite ce
serait d'autant plus surprenant à
auxerre où le modem s'est toujours
positionné clairement à la droite du
centre